BRIAN: HOPE YOU ARE HAVING A
GREAT WEEKEND.
WELCOME TO "ONE NATION."
I'M BRIAN KILMEADE.
THERE WAS ALWAYS AN UNSPOKEN
COMPACT BETWEEN AMERICA AND
THEIR JOURNALISTS.
BUT APPARENTLY THAT COMPACT
BUSTED APART.
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER MONEY
TRAIL SCANDAL AND THE HUNTER
BIDEN SAGA, THE FINDINGS OF THE
DURHAM PROBE.
TRADITIONAL AND SOCIAL MEDIA ARE
BASICALLY IGNORING THEM.
I BLEACH THEIR CHOICE TO IGNORE
STORIES OF THAT MAGNITUDE NEEDS
TO BE INVESTIGATED.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THE MEDIA
IGNORED THE WATERGATE SCANDAL,
OR THE MONICA LEWINSKY SCANDAL,
AND THE ABU GHRAIB PRISON
SCANDAL IN IRAQ WAS IGNORED.
OR THE IRAN CONTRA AFFAIR DURING
THE RONALD REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION?
SO WHAT IS THE SOLUTION NOW?
TESLA'S ELON MUSK TOOK A
MAJORITY STAKE IN TWITTER.
MUSK HAS A PLATFORM AND HE'S IN
CONTROL AND HE'S THE BIGGEST
SHAREHOLDER.
WE KNOW SOCIAL MEDIA GOES OUT OF
ITS WAY TO BLOCK THE TRUTH.
THAT'S THEIR DECISION.
BRINGING.
YOU MAINSTREAM SOURCES TO BE
TOTALLY IGNORES.
CAN MUSK BE THE REALITY CHECK
THE MEDIA NEEDS TO COVER THINGS
MORE FREELY.
PIECING BACK TOGETHER THAT TRU